est à présent notre collègue François
Noël buffet pour le groupe
UMP
monsieur le Président ma question est à
l'attention de Monsieur le Ministre de
l'Intérieur
dans le département du Rhône le préfet
vient de prendre une décision de
réquisition d'un terrain situé sur la
commune d'Oullins afin d'y installer 300
demandeurs d'asile expulsés de la ville
de Lyon à la suite d'une procédure
d'expulsion engagée par le maire de Lyon
président du Grand Lyon
le terrain qui a été choisi et sur une
commune qui est petite 26000 habitants
un petit territoire en politique de la
ville de surcroît accueillant déjà 225
demandeurs d'asile depuis longtemps
sur son sur son territoire
l'émotion est extrêmement grande d'abord
parce que la pression migratoire sur le
département du Rhône est extrêmement
forte ensuite parce que les habitants se
sont mobilisés fortement contre la
manière dont cette décision a été prise
plus de 6000 pétitionnaires aujourd'hui
pour une commune de 26 000 habitants
vous conviendrez que les choses sont
importantes
au plan national nous savons que la
demande d'asile est en augmentation une
augmentation très forte le rapport du
sénateur caoutchi indique même que pour
2013 nous serons à plus de 70 000
demandes
nous savons également que l'OFPRA ne
rend pas les décisions avec la Cour
Nationale des Droits d'asile dans un
délai inférieur à 19 mois aujourd'hui ce
qui est considérable je tiens à
souligner que sous le précédent
gouvernement on était arrivé à
redescendre entre 9 et 10 mois
je voudrais monsieur le ministre attiré
votre attention sur le fait que le
problème tient plusieurs choses d'abord
la difficulté de définir ce qu'est un
pays d'origine sûr et la difficulté
surtout d'avoir une définition commune à
l'échelle de l'Europe ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point c'est
que ces délais d'instructions étant
tellement long qu'il favorise évidemment
les filières d'immigration clandestine
qui souhaitent profiter de l'occasion
pour pouvoir maintenir sur le territoire
des gens qui ne relèvent pas du droit
d'asile auquel nous sommes tous
d'ailleurs attachés enfin il faut
rappeler que sur les années précédentes
sur les
53000 décisions de d'expulsion du
territoire seul 20.000 sont exécutés les
autres restants sur le territoire
national nous produisons donc comme la
remarquer également notre collègue fera
ça et notre collègue carochi nous-même
nos propres situations irrégulières
alors Monsieur le Ministre j'ai trois
questions pour le pouvez-vous intervenir
auprès du préfet pour qu'il modifie sa
décision qu'il revienne sur sa décision
et qu'on puisse reconsidérer la
situation telle qu'elle est aujourd'hui
et telle qu'elle est créée aujourd'hui
au plan national ne serait-il pas
opportun monsieur le ministre d'envoyer
des représentants de l'OFPRA en Albanie
notamment pour peut-être analyser sur
place immédiatement les demandes d'Asie
qui vont être déposées enfin quelle
mesure allez-vous engager pour qu'on ait
une définition unitaire en Europe de
pays d'origine sûr et bien sûr quels
moyens pour exécuter les décisions de
retour merci merci
Monsieur Manuel Valls ministre de
l'Intérieur
sur le Président Mesdames et Messieurs
les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur buffet vous aurez rappelé
d'abord une situation qui est très
tendue et c'est vrai en Rhône-Alpes et
dans le département du Rhône la Région
Rhône-Alpes a connu une hausse de plus
de 50 % du nombre de demandeurs d'asile
dans le département du Rhône ce nombre a
doublé et c'est vrai que Lyon et le
Grand Lyon sont impactés cette situation
critique ce n'est pas le seul
département qui connaisse là connu une
saturation les capacités d'hébergement
ce sont 5700 personnes qui sont
hébergées chaque jour par l'État et le
préfet ce sont devoir veille à la
répartition sur l'ensemble du
département mais malgré ses efforts
conséquent il n'est pas possible de
trouver des solutions d'hébergement pour
tous et cette histoire les solutions à
la veille de l'hiver particulièrement
difficile la capacité d'accueil
dans le Rhône sera augmenté de 900
places durant la période hivernale c'est
pourquoi le préfet a décidé mais je vais
en dire un mot d'héberger sur un terrain
de votre commune
290 demandeurs d'asile qui occupait
depuis le début juillet 2013 une zone à
côté de la gare de Lyon Perrache sous un
autopompe avec près de 100 enfants dans
des conditions terribles j'ai pu
moi-même le voir de mes yeux il y a
quelques jours depuis 2011 d'autres
communes dont la vôtre de
l'agglomération lyonnaise ont participé
à cet effort collectif d'hébergement
mais il est évident que nous ne
tiendrons pas très longtemps avec ce
type de solution par rapport au terrain
d'oulling j'ai demandé je vais demander
au préfet d'organiser autrement la
répartition je vous connais bien je ne
doute pas que vous participerez à cet
effort mais nous allons faire en sorte
que cet accueil de ces populations
soient organisées autrement et j'en
prends auprès de vous l'engagement pour
concerne la réforme du droit d'asile
elle est en cours depuis plusieurs mois
avec une concertation qui est menée par
Valérie l'État et jean-Louis Touraine
notamment pour réduire les délais ils
étaient autour de 20 mois sous le
gouvernement précédent aujourd'hui nous
essayons de le ramener à 16 mois et
l'objectif c'est évidemment neuf mois
mais c'est difficile il faut des moyens
nous les avons donné à l'OFPRA c'est
toute la procédure qui doit être revue
pour réduire les délais au niveau
national dans une concertation au niveau
européen et avec une organisation
beaucoup plus directive pour ce qui
concerne l'accueil sur notre territoire
j'espère et je conclus avec cela
monsieur le sénateur que nous arrivons
et saumons souhait à une proposition
consensuelle parce que sur ce sujet là
nous avons besoin qu'au niveau national
comme au niveau local nous trouvions les
voies d'un consensus pour régler ce
problème de l'asile et notamment du sort
des déboutés du droit d'asile